if you want to support more 7 Deadly
Sins content like this you can also
visit anime upper calm and purchase
anime inspired shirts including
bestsellers like Mele Otisfield the
wrath and Eskin or praise the sun fans
of the channel also get a whole 25% off
just use the code uproar 25 at checkout
[Music]
what up guys goes on here and today I
wanted to talk about a theory that Miele
and Mellie Otis are twin brothers or at
the very least brothers after all I'm
not saying this is definitely true or
even the most likely thing that could
happen but I wanted to look at all the
evidence in the text supporting such a
theory and then we can have a discussion
about it I'd love to hear what you guys
think in the comments do you think they
are related or is there another reason
they look so similar in your view before
we get into I just want to say a big
thank you to you guys for helping us set
a new record my house strong is demon
king Mele Otis video had the best start
of any video in our channel's history so
thank you very much for that it was
unbelievable and it shows that the hype
is real right now
remember to Like and subscribe for more
7 Deadly Sins content and keep in mind
guys
there will be manga spoilers in this
video possibly even spoilers that
haven't even happened yet hopefully so
let's start with Mele Otis's wanted
poster the poster looks exactly like
esta rosa in the beginning we are told
that these posters are updated every
year
thus the creator of the wanted poster
supposedly took a guess as to how
malleolus would look after 10 years and
this is the image they came up with
there's not really much need to think
too hard about this poster in the
beginning after all malleolus doesn't
noticeably age in 10 years because a
he's a demon and they aged slower than
humans and B as we later figure out he
has a curse placed on him by the demon
king and supreme deity making him pretty
much immortal and that curse keeps him
from aging for these reasons we can
easily forget about Mele Otis's wanted
poster which was introduced in the very
first chapter of the manga at least
until chapter 113 in this chapter
elizabeth is dreaming and she sees the
same Mellie Otis wanted poster from the
first episode then someone who looks
exactly like the poster shows up then
she asked
is that you then the real
younger-looking Mellie Otis wakes her up
from the dream however at the end of the
chapter we get our first real look at
esta rosa and he looks exactly like the
poster and exactly like the Mellie Otis
that she dreamed of thus as soon as a
cirrhosis introduced it is done so in a
way that unmistakeably links him to
Mellie Otis so how is this similarity in
appearance explained in the beginning it
is explained away to an extent because
we are led to believe that Esther OSA is
Mellie Otis's brother there's the
mystery of why a younger brother would
age quicker than an older brother but if
we ignore this then being brothers sons
of the same demon king is a pretty good
reason for them to look alike what is
interesting is that in Chapter 176 when
Esther OSA is fighting Mellie Otis he
says he loves him and when he shoves his
leg in tamela's chest he says this
brings back memories Mellie Otis let me
hear your voice again in this chapter we
also get what must be a fake flashback
but nonetheless it is interesting that
Esther OSes younger self in the
flashback looks exactly like Mellie Otis
does as he temporarily kills Mellie Otis
Esther OSA is crying he says goodbye
brother my beloved Mellie Otis we don't
even see zelgius who we know is Mellie
Otis's real brother shed a tear over
melioidosis death but somehow esther OSA
feels a connection strong enough to cry
interestingly enough we find out in
Chapter 272 that the demon king and
Mellie Otis cannot recall memories of
Esther OSA all they can recall is a
summarized description of him that goes
like this although he is the son of the
demon king he was born without the
powers of darkness a weak hearted young
boy who couldn't even hurt a fly pitying
him the demon king granted a serosa
commandment so considering this why does
a serosa claim that he can recall
memories of Mellie Otis's voice if
fabricated memories tend to result in
not being able to recall specific things
why can a serosa recall melio Lisa's
voice when he's crying out is it
possible that as with Broly and Goku
from Dragon Ball Z Esther also
recognizes a baby Mellie Otis is crying
I realize this is a stretch but
nonetheless it might be useful to keep
in mind as we move forward let's go to
chapter 230
cusack compares esther osa to Mellie
Otis when he says it's impossible to
read what he is truly thinking or
feeling just like Mellie Otis as we've
seen Mellie Oda sinestro's are
constantly being compared and this will
only continue as we go on as we know
Esther OSA Ismail
the strongest Archangel of the goddess
clan while Mellie Otis was the strongest
commandant of the demon clan mile is
associated with the Sun and light while
Mellie Otis is associated with a
darkness like yin and yang
thus isn't it interesting that when mile
absorbs enough darkness in the form of
the commandments he starts to think that
he is Mellie Otis if they were born as
twins with the main difference being
that Mellie Otis was associated with
darkness
mal with light it would make sense that
once filled with enough darkness mal
would start to view himself as Mellie
Otis weld led me to finally want to make
this video is chapter 299 where we see
that Mellie Otis has aged after
absorbing the 10 commandments probably
because he has succeeded in breaking the
demon Kings curse and the 3,000 years
have caught up with him a bit he looks
exactly like my El now before this we
could say that Mellie Otis looked
somewhat more related to zelgius because
they still look like children while Maya
l had the appearance of an adult however
we do know that demons age Mellie Otis
is dad the demon king is proof of that
it just appears to take them longer to
age than it does for goddesses but now
the unbelievable similarity between
Mellie Otis's looks and miles looks is
impossible to ignore
Mellie Otis looks way more similar to my
Al than to zelgius and Maya looks way
more similar to Mellie Otis than to ludo
shell too to look much more similar to
each other than to their true brothers
and that cannot just be a coincidence
for these reasons it makes sense that
some people want to believe that Mellie
Otis and Milo are brothers but let's
look at what the implications of this
would be one possibility is that Mellie
Otis and Maya are twins born from the
demon king and the supreme deity we are
never shown who Mellie Otis's mother is
so it might be the supreme deity as we
know we never met a female demon queen
and we never met a male supreme deity
the male demon king and the female
supreme deity are usually always
mentioned to
and their powers are consistently
compared the demon king is the
overbearing father figure of the series
while the supreme deity or goddess is
the overbearing mother figure of the
series the possibility of them having
children together was even foreshadowed
when Merlin was called the Blessed
daughter of the demon king and the
supreme goddess in chapter 248 it is
explained that Merlin negotiated with
the two gods on her own meaning the
demon king and supreme goddess
her term for gifts of her own liking the
demon king gave detailed information on
all of the secret arts and mysteries of
the underworld and divine protection
that could defend against the
brainwashing of the goddesses the
supreme deity bestowed the child divine
protection able to nullify any and all
manner of dark curses and Commandments
you can see together in a panel the two
outstretched arms of both the demon king
and deity although they're costly
competing with each other the two
so-called gods have worked together
multiple times in the past they work
together to destroy the city of beli
Alwyn where Merlin was from to punish
her for deceiving them they also work
together to punish meliodas
and Elizabeth it seems kind of weird for
mortal enemies to stand side by side and
punish their children together but
that's what we see in chapter 224 so it
seems like they have met multiple times
and had no issues working together and
if Mellie Oda is a demon and Elizabeth a
goddess can get together that it is at
least a possibility that the demon king
and supreme deity can - now let's
address some possible problems with such
a theory first thought wouldn't that
mean that Elizabeth and melly Otis are
related as we know sometimes an anime
being related doesn't really stop
attraction but let's explore the
possibilities in more detail we don't
know exactly how the relationship
between these two gods as they are
called and their children works in a way
all the goddesses can be viewed as
children of the supreme deity yet you
still have goddesses falling for other
goddesses like narrow Bostaph elf or
lunar shell we must keep in mind that we
don't really know the exact truth
surrounding Elizabeth's birth or
melioidosis birth perhaps Elizabeth
turns out to be an adopted
daughter alternatively we should
remember that the demon king and supreme
deity are viewed as gods in the world of
the seven deadly sins just as Adam and
Eve came from God and yet were lovers
it's possible that the fact that Milly
Otis and Elizabeth came from gods
makes a difference in the case of the
series in which case we cannot project
the norms of our own human societies
onto them then there's the question of
why malleolus and mile are not half
demon and half goddess when it comes to
their powers and appearances it seems
that Mellie Otis is a pure demon and
Maya as a pure goddess one explanation
is that every time a demon and goddess
have a baby it cannot be both a dominant
demon gene or a dominant goddess gene
must take over this would explain why we
haven't seen any half demons and half
goddesses around since at some point
there had to be a demon who had a kid
with a goddess in the long history of
the seven deadly sins world and yet we
never see any half-breeds
as a result the fraternal twins Mellie
Otis and Miele each took on the traits
of the other parent thus one became a
demon and the other a goddess this would
even explain why they age differently
mial aged quicker because goddesses age
quicker than demons another very
interesting thing to consider is the
fact that mile a goddess or more
specifically an archangel is able to use
demon magic the fact that Miele could
even use demon magic as a goddess might
point towards the fact that he has some
demon blood inside of him even if it's
not dominant if this was the case it
would in fact be true that the demon
king had a son without the powers of
darkness he would not have real memories
of him though because the goddess would
have taken him for herself since he was
a goddess it makes sense that the
supreme deity would give the most
powerful grace to her own son just as
the demon king gave a commandment and
additional power that he didn't give to
anyone else to zelgius his own son
if Mele Otis and Maya were twins it
would make sense that Miele would have
heard Mellie Otis crying out before it
makes sense why mild then esther osa
would cry when he thought he killed
Mellie Otis because there was in fact a
real connection there the poster from
the very first chapter and the
cannae similarity between the adult
meliodas and male would also make sense
if this theory turned out to be true so
yeah there are some thoughts about the
theory that Mele ODIs Mao might be twin
brothers let me know what you think
despite the fact that it's just the
theory I had a lot of fun making this
video and looking for possible clues in
the manga but whether they turn out to
be brothers or not no one can deny that
there is a significant connection
between Maya and Mellie Otis that will
become relevant later on in this series
too much groundwork has been laid in the
manga all the clues pointing to this
important connection let me know if you
have any theories of your own behind the
nature of this connection or if you just
noticed even more clues that I missed
anyways that's it for today's video
thank you so much for watching if you
liked the video make sure to smash that
like button to let me know also if you
haven't don't forget to subscribe and
hit that magic youtube bell for more 7
Deadly Sins videos let me know what kind
of videos you are burning up to see in
the comments and it may just be the next
video you see if you want to keep up to
date and have it to like seven deadly
sins memes too then you can follow us on
instagram and twitter at anime uproar
feel free to send us dankmemes
you want to share both migos and and my
brother Animax love memes so that will
definitely make our day if you want to
support more 7 Deadly Sins content like
this you can also visit anime upper calm
and purchase anime inspired shirts
including bestsellers like Mele
Otisfield the wrath and esken or praise
the sun fans of the channel also get a
whole 25% off just use the code uproar
25 at checkout thank you so much for all
of your support and until next time see
us space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]